no matter what your life circumstances
are the the message is wake up where
does where does past guilt which I think
you're sort of reference you know just
fit into this because we mentioned right
before we started that I've been on tour
with Jordan Peterson and during the q
and A's I see so many people that will
say to him you know I just read your
book and I'm applying the twelve rules
for life and my life is better my
relationships better I'm not doing drugs
whatever whatever it may be
I've mended relationships etc etc but
they have trouble getting over some sort
of past guilt yeah and I think what
you're describing here is the first step
in getting away from that but I think a
lot of people think it's something that
you can do like this right but but it's
not no you need to recognize where it
comes from how it arises in you of
course guilt is related to grievance
well when it refers to another person
it's a grievance you have a resentment
or grievance towards another person when
it refers to yourself then it's called
guilt by it always refers to something
that was that either you did to somebody
that you now recognize as bad in some
way not ethical you did something
perhaps when you were younger perhaps
you brought up your children in a way
that you now recognize as dysfunctional
in some ways or you injured somebody or
you inflicted suffering on somebody
whether it's emotional suffering mental
suffering even physical suffering in
extreme cases you might even have killed
somebody in a very extreme cases and
that brings about guilt
now guilt is something that you did that
you now recognize as bad this becomes a
thought form in your head it becomes
incorporated into your sense of self
what you don't realize is
you did something because you didn't
your consciousness your level of
consciousness will at that time
manifested that kind of behavior no
human being can manifest behavior that's
beyond the level of consciousness so if
you inflict it harm on somebody
the ego tends to then make it into an
identity for yourself and that brings
about guilt when you see through my that
this is your sense of self is guilty
that can be a huge ego boost they can
also be a huge ego boost to declare
somebody else as guilty and somebody who
did something to me so people carry a
grievance or resentment sometimes for
many many years and then again what they
are doing is they're transforming
somebodies I call it unconscious
behavior when you inflict suffering on
another human being except of course
self-defense or whatever but you inflict
suffering on any life form or a human
being you do it it's it's unconscious
you Jesus is supposed to have said on
the cross forgive them for they know not
what they do
translated into modern terminology is
they are unconscious they know not what
they do so people do all kinds of things
sometimes in States after they've taken
drugs they become even more unconscious
or they've consumed alcohol they'd be
makes you more unconscious even with
they're not more unconscious in normal
unconsciousness by unconscious by the
way and perhaps need to explain what I
mean by unconscious which is in
spiritual terms in conventional usage
unconscious means obviously you're right
of lost consciousness but in spiritual
terms
unconscious means you are at the mercy
of the conditioning of your mind and
your emotions the ways in which your
emotion has been conditioned you're
being run by that conditioning there is
no way that this young being has any
awareness of their conditioning there's
no awareness whatsoever and the human
being who has zero awareness perhaps not
to be cooked throughout their lives in
moments
when they I very unconsciously get
triggered by something as I said to take
drugs whatever they'll become zero
awareness and then they do what they do
later you look back on that and and then
you erroneously incorporate that time of
your life when you you weren't even
there
you were run by an automatic program in
your mind and in your emotional field
you weren't even there but the ego will
transform it into an identity and since
I I did this is now part of who I am or
it will do to to somebody else
there was a long time when I had
resentment towards my father because my
father was pretty unconscious except
very late in life at a very strong ego
and living with him as a child was
living with an unexploded bomb that
could go off at any moment we get these
intense rages would suddenly come
several times a week so I lived in a
constant state of kind of background
anxiety but his brain is his bomb going
to explode again next and then for a
long time in my twenties I had a
resentment towards him until I went to
the shifting consciousness and I
suddenly realized he he did what he had
to do there wasn't enough awareness in a
drill act any different so he was at the
mercy of his own conditioning and once
you see that you don't wanna make it
into an identity for him and so you free
him and really perhaps this is the
meaning of forgiveness you can forgive
yourself by not making unconscious
behavior in your past into an identity
for yourself or for somebody else now a
question may arise this is an
interesting point now does that mean
people are not really responsible for
that they do so that's that's an
interesting question in ultimate terms
is to say it is true they are not
responsible for
they do but they will have to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness
because we humans are meant to become
more conscious here and one of the ways
or even one of the perhaps the main way
in which a very unconscious human
evolves eventually or potentially is by
suffering the consequences of their
unconsciousness and sometimes the
consequences might be they have to go to
prison it doesn't so but it does even if
you meet a prisoner it's important if
they did something in the past they
let's say they killed somebody in the
past of course they have to suffer the
consequences and consciousness but when
you meet a human being like that you can
still you may be able to to sense that
there's more to this human being than
this this unconscious person so how does
that play into your perspective on free
will then free will ultimately does not
come in until there's some awareness in
you that's where free will comes from
until you have some awareness you are
run by the conditioning of your mind and
so you have no choice
the element of choice comes in when you
become aware for example of your the
thoughts that go through your head and
you might realize suddenly and for some
people that's the first time they awaken
spiritually when they realize that for
years they've had a voice in their head
talking to them which could be a
monologue it could be a dialogue you
could have a conversation with yourself
you can you know you can beat yourself
up and say why why you're no good enough
aren't you lonely it's on the part of
your cells as well well I'm doing my
best I'm just I can't I can't do it I'm
not I'm not good enough the voice in the
head for some people the spiritual
awakening comes when they become aware
that there's a voice in their head and
there's the awareness at the moment is
the awareness you might even be able to
choose to let go of a certain thought a
repetitive thought that you don't need
an
more that you don't want anymore and
then you you surrender it or you breathe
it out you don't need it you reckon an
emotion but sometimes people's and the
grip of strong emotions but if there's a
little more awareness there if at let's
say it's anger you're suddenly anger
arises but in the background you're
aware that this emotion of anger so
there's a small element of choices come
in do you want to then attract this
person if there's awareness you can
observe the anger but maintain longer
may no longer need to act it out I'm not
talking about suppressing but
recognizing it's the more awareness you
have or presence the more choices in
your life and then it's only then that
you actually become truly intelligent
because this awareness is not an IQ
thing the way you can have I've met
highly intelligent people with one or
two or three PhDs academics others we
are completely unconcerned aware still
just completely in their minds and
people who do in their personal lives
often very dysfunctional personal lives
so it's not to be equated with
intelligence this awareness it's what do
you make of that life actually so if
there's someone that exists in that
state all the time but then becomes any
you know a world-changing scientist or
mathematician or or athlete or whatever
it takes they have to stay in that
whether it's consciously or not they
have to stay in that mode of thinking
what what do you make of that life that
maybe doesn't lock in to hearing the
inner voice well it can be a very
extremely unbalanced life and no matter
how intelligent they are even people who
have there are some people who are very
creative in one area but the rest of
their lives is completely unbalanced and
then some people are almost destroyed by
the by the UM the lack of balance in
their lives
select famous people like even some
famous pop artists who were quite quite
creative in the way Michael Jackson for
example um as a person he's just come
just I mean he's passed away now but I
remember seeing him an interview as a
person he's just got much to say and
it's a teammate and from but the moment
he moves he makes a dance movement or
just a power flow through him and I saw
that but these the important thing is
the this this the creative intelligence
needs to come into the interest of Allah
your knife needs to become a work of art
a creative work of art not just a little
area in your life so what the world
needs is actually not more intelligence
it doesn't need more knowledge I mean
we're just we're drowning in facts and
information that we don't need more of
that to use an old-fashioned word what
the world needs is wisdom wisdom is
inseparable from awareness it it arises
out of awareness without wisdom you are
torn you know you may be identified with
the the polarities of life there were
perhaps worth mentioning here you know
the ancient yin and yang Chinese way of
looking at the world they see the yin is
the feminine principle and the yang is
the masculine principle so these the
polarities are everywhere in life this
is a very for Western mind is a very
strange way of looking at things but the
the Chinese philosophy ancient Chinese
philosophy says this is there's a play
of the the world is a manifestation of
the play between yin and yang
the feminine masculine principles you
may remember the symbol of yin and yang
the birth and here too you can be you
can be in the grip of a particular
energy movement without awareness you
can get into the grip of yang and then
you would become quite destructive if
you go to an extreme a country can be in
the grip of yang energy like Germany was
Russia China any country where this
dictatorship is in the grip of an
extreme grip of Yang and traditionally
society in at least in the West has been
dominated by the yang energy with
occasional interludes of yin in between
but relatively insignificant for example
the Romantic movement in the 19th
century in art and literature was again
coming in but not for too long
so would you put the Enlightenment it
again stated the Enlightenment there was
a bit of yin coming in yes yes but to
the first half of the 20th century was
an extreme manifestation of yang the
world wars the genocide in in Germany in
Russia and China Cambodia in other
places absurd unconsciousness yang Frank
then the world the Western world
especially experienced as a reaction to
the extreme yang an influx of yin it
started in the 60s actually a very
strong influx of game and with that came
the woman's women's movement and all
those things more empathy towards other
human beings came in also an openness to
work to support spirituality more
instead of the rigid patterns of
institutionalized religion there was an
openness towards influx also
of Eastern spirituality coming into the
West there was an embassy over with this
is where the embassy will with a
disadvantaged humans came from an
embassy to the suffering of people who
are physically disabled be mentally
disabled or the so called marginalized
all those things this is a wonderful
thing human could sense their suffering
so more empathy came up and this was a
great thing it's a necessary thing
education changed completely from being
dominated by the yang energy discipline
and yang and now education became more
and more permissive you do your own
things it became so permissive that
eventually there was no structure
anymore it was all and schools became
chaotic and family many families became
totally chaotic and so and the wonderful
empathy towards other human beings
turned into political correctness
quickly the world was moving towards an
extreme of a yen to counterbalance but
there was no awareness so people first
were in the grip of the yang movement
and identified with that as a collective
and now a significant portion of the
Western civilization not all but a
significant portion of the population is
in the grip of a yen movement and it's
not stopping it's going to an extreme
where something that it was initially
good and necessary yeah now anything
that goes to an extreme becomes
destructive and another ancient saying
in Greek philosophies nothing in excess
nothing in excess so now the collective
is is in the grip not all of it but she
gave him part the especially the the
mass of the media
universities and so on strongly in the
grip of yen Germany is a
the example they like to go to extremes
they went extreme of Yang they became
the most aggressive country in Europe
and now they are going into extreme
again they are the most compassionate
country in Europe except Sweden the most
company opened their borders completely
so please we want to help you this is
this is this consists of two things
there is the compassion that arises when
the incomes in there is another element
that needs to be mentioned yes there's
also guilt which plays its part to the
combination of of guilt and yen energy
so yen is symbolized as this this is yen
receptive open this is yang you can see
yang is a mask in the thrusting
principle it's almost a sexual yin yang
so yang says let's close the borders on
extreme form of yang says let's expand
our country and then close the borders
let's attack the neighboring countries
and then we'll be even bigger the
extreme of the incest no borders at all
an American book and this it's if it
feels so good to be able to say how can
you deny human beings a much better life
how can we deny it feels so wonderful
just say that but what's lacking is
wisdom and compassion is there and it's
wonderful so you have yin and yang
what's missing is it they need to be
instead of two polarities you need to be
a triangle at the apex of the triangle
you need to have awareness if there's
nothing honest when you don't need to go
to an extreme of either general yang you
know it's so interesting because I
wasn't really planning on doing anything
sort of political with you but actually
I think in the last few minutes you've
given me as good political analysis to
sort of where we are so without getting
into the
nitty-gritty of politics if your premise
is basically right and this is why I
always say the road to hell is paved
with good intentions but know that I'm
frustrated with right now that you're
describing as in I don't believe there
are evil people there can be there can
be bad actors within that let's say or
people that aren't acting in their
conscious but I don't believe that the
bulk of them are but if we're active if
we're right now we're caught between
this how does the good decent person
that I think most people are that can
check in and out of their higher self
and all of those things but that want a
decent world how do we how do we help
these sides to get to that place well
first you have to be careful with
yourself so that you do not get drawn to
either one or the other extreme because
now the reactive mode of course - fine -
again it would be to go - fine - yang
and so a society they it was totally
into yin would produce fascism again
that's the danger so the individual
needs to be aware that they don't want
the reactivity so that you remain aware
so you don't contribute to the
polarization in the world so what what
you contribute whether it's only social
media or in person when you speak to
somebody or you write something be
careful that you do not confuse also
somebody's mental emotional position
which may be whether they are there with
who they are and then regard him as an
enemy
the ego feels strengthened the more
enemies it can have the stronger it
feels there's always the tendencies the
unconscious ego to make others into
enemies so it's we need to develop
enough awareness to be able to conduct a
conversation with another human being
without regarding the other who might
hold very very different mental
positions as an enemy I was very happy
to see recently happen to see an
interview on YouTube with a guy who has
come quite
Longway Russell Brand mm-hmm has come a
long way with the other briefs doing
great things now even anybody who hasn't
seen him matter for a long time should
see him again
he met with Candice Owens oh I saw and
they exactly pretty incredible they had
an interview he's on the Left she's on
the right they were in many ways
opposing opposite viewpoints respected
each other as human beings without
making the other into an enemy that is a
wonderful step if they can do it but
other people don't do it it just
requires a little bit of awareness so
that you can then have a conversation
and it's only by having a conversation
that you can find somewhere a middle of
a middle way some of this is a Buddhist
expression Buddhism is called the middle
way you find the middle way somewhere I
if we don't have conversations with
others we'll have different viewpoints
then the there will be deterioration and
eventually they would it might even be
violence
so it's interesting because I know you
talk a lot about the collective
conscious which obviously I mean look
you happen to see me on YouTube that
brought us here now your message can get
out to you know tons of other people and
all of that stuff which is absolutely
incredible so that's the that's the
great part of the internet that I think
has fed the collective unconsciousness
unconscious but then there's another
part of it where we seemingly are just
fighting all day long and you mentioned
before we're distracted all day long so
if we're standing on a corner we
automatically go to our phone do you
think that level of distraction and
Technology and our our adolescents
relative to knowing what is really going
on by having the world in your pocket at
all times do you think that is leading
us to to a sort of strange existential
crisis that actually could have never
happened before just because of the the
speed with which yes we can communicate
and learn and and ate and all those
yes well they supposed what is community
what is communicated through these
devices but the very fact that there is
this device this was a many years ago
there was a book by Marshall McLuhan it
says the medium is the message
it was about television but the the
nature of the device itself we we need
to be very careful because what it does
is it contributes to the clutter of our
minds so no matter potentially it it can
be a very beneficial thing to connect
with humans through these devices but at
the moment the dangers it might be
destructive are greater I can see what
it does to children who from an early
age interact with these and no longer
able to have personal relationships
increasing number of children have
attention deficit disorder now what is
attention deficit disorder they can't
focus on anything for very long anymore
what does that do to human consciousness
what does it do to a civilization
if you must grow up now without the
ability to focus on tension for very
long because ending any creative act
requires you to be present with
something a period of time to give it
attention and if humans lose the ability
to give attention then they lose the
ability to be creative if they lose the
ability to be creative they lose the
ability even to solve their problems
because the problems that they have
created
it requires wisdom and true creativity
to solve those problems so all kinds of
scenarios are possible scenario of a
breakdown of civilization within two
generations is a possibility but these
things if these things I need to learn
how to use these devices in the same way
that we have to learn how to use our
minds because they are an extension of
our
so if become more aware of what our mind
is doing then it might be easier also do
to handle these devices because they are
an extension and amplification of the
mind and the dysfunction that we see on
the internet with all these
dysfunctional behavior and so on it's
just it's an externalization and an
amplification of the dysfunction of the
human ego you can just see it much more
clearly now it's all for everybody to
see and that might be a good thing to
see it because then become really aware
of it what are we doing to ourselves
it's a good question to ask what are we
doing to ourselves this is becoming
insane and the moment you see that it is
insane then there's some sanity in you
because nobody who knows they're insane
is completely insane the really insane
people don't know the answer so if you
see the insanity in the work way that we
collectively communicate you say ok I am
NOT going to be part of that it's
necessary to see it and then your
responsibility as an individual is not
to feed it to stay conscious to stay
present so that your input is conscious
and does not seek to destroy other human
beings and deem demonize other you
dehumanize and demonize other human
beings
so you view that really as the antidote
let's say to the mob culture that we
have because there is this you can feel
this you know it's funny I this morning
I was scrolling your Twitter feed in it
and your Twitter feed is basically a
breath of fresh air it's like when I was
reading it I could there's like a breath
and it's and it's Pleasant and you know
there's there's some of your sayings and
some of the ways that you want to help
people think clearly one of the things
but that's so the reverse of the way
most of Twitter is and I'm part of that
other world and sometimes sometimes I
feed it and I try not to but you know
I'm not perfect either
but I do see this thing where where the
mob is sort of moving or
on Twitter and sometimes it comes to get
me to yeah and there's this there's an
innate human feeling you see something
and it has a lot of attention and it's
shiny and it's whatever and that
everyone wants to get in but basically
you're saying if you would take that
breath if you would just say I don't
want in on this that eventually you can
actually you can almost pull other
people out of it to by your own behavior
yes because this isn't just about you
yes
also not to feed other if other people
post negative things about you in many
many cases non-reaction is the best
thing instead of feeding at hours and I
need to learn I will try to take that
one that applies both offline and online
in your personal life too often it's
just well I believe Jesus was talking
about non reaction when he's talked
about turning the other cheek I don't
think is to be taken literally but it
means when somebody at somebody attacks
you not not physically it's an analogy
he uses it's a parable turn the other
cheek is just be free of reaction and
that that very quickly deflates even the
other person's ego it doesn't if the ego
needs the reaction it needs the
reactivity so that's a powerful thing
but how do you avoid then just becoming
a pushover within that well in some
situations something needs to be said
but even then that can come from you
could say let's especially if you're
with somebody that kind of behavior is
unacceptable you can say that in a
conscious way rather than in a
destructive and aggressive way you can
one can actually be very firm and
conscious or when you say no to somebody
it doesn't have to be aggressive it's
just unique a clear is I call it a high
quality no somebody says can you lend me
again
the $2,000 i need i know are still owe
you 20,000 but I need some more and then
and then not to make the other engine
enemy just know I'm sorry can't do it
anymore it's a high quality no that's a
your present well you say it and then
you can set boundaries if necessary so
in some cases something needs to be said
we need to do something but in many
other cases complete non reactivity can
be very very powerful what gives you the
most amount of joy in your life now the
little things in life the little things
walking around in nature sometimes
sitting quietly in the room just being I
love being nature I still enjoy
traveling and the greatest joy is
teaching giving talks because that's my
life purpose and so once every every
time I engage in my life purpose then
I'm really in a state of joy and
heightened aliveness and that's why I'm
still doing it yeah would you say you're
are you an optimist inherently as far as
human destiny is concerned you mean or
humanity or in general yeah and I don't
mean it personally actually I mean it's
just in the in the wider world or are
you hopeful oh yes I'm opting I'm well I
sometimes call it I'm a long-term
optimist I will say world-weary optimist
short-term I don't know it's possible
who knows where humanity is going right
now nobody could predict where it's
going all the individual or the
individual can only take responsibility
for their own state of consciousness but
they ought that matters very much the
because your state of consciousness the
travel determines the way in which you
experience reality and that has many
repercussions you affect many other
humans through your
state of consciousness so let's don't
underestimate the importance of your
state of consciousness in the present
moment in there's so much more we can do
here but I want to be respectful of your
time so I'll ask you one more and then
when we end this I'm going to beg you to
come back but if someone's watching this
right now and is really in what Jordan
Peterson would describe as the state of
chaos or the state that you were in in
in your late 20s before you had your
awakening and they hear you and they say
well just you know taking that first
breath isn't gonna do it if they're
really just out of sorts right now
what would be some some way that you
think you could help shake them out of
it give them something concrete that
would help them click you know stop on
this thing and and fix themselves or
begin the process that's a no yeah well
the best starting point is the present
moment now whatever I say any advice I
gave it's quite possible if not likely
that they're conditioned mind will deny
what I say and it'll say that's not
going to work so don't believe what I
say now if your mind says it is not
going to work don't believe what your
mind says just try what I've got what
I'm saying now so we become more fully
conscious of the present moment right
now because this that's all there ever
is your entire life is experienced and
unfolds in the present moment most
humans don't seem to even realize that
because they always live as if some
other moment we're more important than
this one you need to honor this moment
it's the basis for the soak for the
future all that unfolds which never
comes because when it comes it's and now
and the past never happened except when
you remember it it's over and you
remember it now so coming to the present
moment
be aware of your breathing and another
one I recommend anybody discover
actually very powerful bit sounds almost
too simple but it's very powerful
feel the aliveness inside your body and
if you don't know what I mean are
usually I advise people to close their
eyes hold their hand like this and ask
themselves without looking at my hand or
moving my hand how can I know whether my
hand is still there that question
requires you to direct attention into
your hand and then after a few seconds
you'll probably feel a little bit of a
tingling or liveness in your hand that
is the beginning of being able to feel
what I call the inner body
this is the the energy field that the
that pervades every cell in the body if
you can start with the hands then you
feel your legs your feet your hands
simultaneously and then you incorporate
the totality of your body and so your
attention is moved from your mind you're
taking consciousness into the body so
one could say you're now inhabiting your
body consciously and when you it's a
very very lovely feeling and you'll
notice that you're no longer thinking
very much you can't and all the the
problems that you have to a large extent
we are created by dysfunctional thinking
and the emotions that accompany
dysfunctional thinking most of the
problems reside in your mind so if you
are able to become more present then you
access a higher or deeper dimension of
consciousness and to become more present
you have to be able to step out of your
mind without losing consciousness
so the consciousness the goes into the
body and the body becomes an anchor you
can hold it through several minutes at a
time becomes an anchor for being present
become as present as you can also
present of sense perceptions it's very
important sense perceptions can also
bring you into the present moment an
expression you could use is come to your
senses
in both meanings of the work expression
come to your senses look around because
consciously take everything in without
label it is needing to label it mentally
and then you suddenly aware of your
surroundings you aware of your inner
energy field you're in the present
moment and in the present moment there's
no problem
competent is not an emergency sometimes
yes then you have to act but it's not an
emergency he has no problem then your
ability to deal with your so-called
problems becomes much greater if you're
able to access the power of your
presence then when you choose to deal
with your problems saying okay now I
apply focused thought what can I do when
you return to presence it's always going
thinking back in to learn what presence
is it's there it's the the kingdom of
heaven is at hand sati it's right here
it's right here don't look for it
elsewhere and then you realize the a lot
of the unhappiness in one's life the
Buddha called it dukkha suffering he
says every human suffers unless they
have awakened but and a lot of the
suffering is not due to your life
circumstances or the most people think
it is the the larger part of your
suffering is due to your mental
commentary about your life circumstances
your mind is telling you something that
creates the unhappiness even you can
test it out you in a simple situation
you're in line somewhere you get
irritated it's taking too long you're
waiting you get very angry and irritated
then experiment how would I experience
the situation without adding any thought
to it if I didn't add any thoughts to
this moment just and then suddenly well
it's actually fine
it's not before you aren't happy but we
are not unhappy because of the you had
to wait you weren't happy because of the
narrative in your mind so there are
millions of people who carry very toxic
narratives in their mind and they call
it my life that's not it's a it's a
terrible burden they carry around it
doesn't have to be like that and the
essence of all spirituality is to be
able to step out of that realize if only
a little bit of self transcendence which
is inner spaciousness and then that
grows and then you can begin to sense
there is a power in you that transcends
the person and that is also the place
where you can transcend the the feelings
of happiness and unhappiness which
fluctuate continuously I'm not saying
you've it's not happiness that you
ultimately find happiness it's a little
bit superficial I've made it in the next
day or the opposite it's something that
transcends happiness and unhappiness
it's a deep sense of rootedness in being
of a deep sense of inner peace that
really have nothing much to do with your
personal circumstances I've had letters
from people in prison who have written
to me said I feel free now because I've
read your book and I've practiced it and
my life is transformed and now I'm just
teaching others from many letters from
prison prisoners so it's it's well no
matter what your life circumstances are
the the message is wake up wake up out
of complete identification with your
mind and so let's you're the ultimate
purpose in life it is to awaken this has
been a an absolute pleasure I think that
I I'm not I think I know that I had a
few of those brief fleeting moments
while we were here and I thank you for
that and I think if my audience gets
even 1% of that through the internet
waves they're all out
I think this will be something that I
will always remember I hope we can do
this again because we thank you get
started here I normally tell the Twitter
handle of my guests but in this case I'm
going to look at the camera and tell you
guys just to take a breath